ok on va le voir Monsieur janvier voir
comment ça va c'est une équipe qui
travaille à préserver la dignité d'aimer
qui ne sont plus autonomes on vient voir
une personne âgée de 89 ans qui a un
trône neuro cognitif majeur ils
accompagnent et soignent ces personnages
dans ce jeudi matin on rencontre
Monsieur janvier qui ne sort plus de sa
petite chambre il mange toujours ici et
collectionne les couverts qui
remplissent toutes ces armoires comme ça
vous allez avoir de la place
docteur Nathalie zen vide les armoires
avec l'infirmière Robin boulian une
façon d’établir un lien avec lui et un
prétexte pour le sculpter
plus ça va plus qu'on s'aperçoit que en
perte d'autonomie puis qui est capable
de rester tout seul sauf que lui
clairement veut rester parce qu'il
réalise pas qui a un problème de santé
le vieil homme suggère de se raser aux
ciseaux
clairement la résidence pour personnage
gênait plus un environnement assez
sécuritaire pour lui on tente de
l'accompagner doucement vers la suite on
réussit à le maintenir ici pour
l'instant
puisqu'on veut c'est réussir à le
relocaliser ailleurs ou ils vont mieux
répondre à ses besoins en évitant
toujours qui se retrouvent à l'urgence
chaque visite est un geste de plus pour
tenter d'éviter l'hospitalisation
prochain stop chez une octogénaire qui
s'ouvre aussi de problèmes cognitifs je
suis arrivé ici la 2 semaines à la veine
conjonctivite à laver l'oeil et purulent
à Stana premium se déplacer locataire
dans un demi-so-sol elle semble de moins
en moins capable de vivre seul est-ce
que les étourdissements c'est plus ou
moins qu'avant c'est moins qu'avant et
la chuté et s'est blessé il y a quelques
semaines la tête vous avez
ici aussi on soigne en attendant un
hébergement plus adapté peut-être une
résidence pour personnages semi autonome
stabiliser la patience puis le faire un
espèce de réhabilitation avec elle en
attendant de trouver une relocalisation
qui correspond à ses besoins
Robin boulian est la docteur Zane
travaille en collaboration avec le CLSC
ils ont tous le même objectif éviter des
séjours nuisibles à l'hôpital la
personne va attendre un hébergement à
l'hôpital donc c'est ça qu'on veut plus
faire on veut désengorger les hôpitaux
pour que les hôpitaux puissent donner
des soins actifs pour l'instant la
gériatrie à domicile est l'exception
plutôt que la norme mais c'est le genre
d'initiative que le gouvernement veut
multiplier pour éviter que les hôpitaux
ne soient paralysés ici David gentil les
Radio-Canada Montréal